second major league start for jesus
lizardo his first was against the texas
rangers he said one appearance against
these astros out of the bullpen in his
major league debut
so the astros get their lead off man
aboard here in the first inning
he has reticus batting at 240 with a
home run and four runs batted in
surprising bounce to olson he fires the
second for one rosado hustling over to
cover first and that's a double play
it's never an easy double play to turn
but the a's did so and lozardo was able
to hustle over there and actually
get to the bag and that'll bring up
bregman who's batting at 230.
chapman's got it chapman will throw on
the run and that will do it castro's
failed to score with the a's coming up
in the bottom half
the right-hander christian javier goes
to work on the as bottom of the first
timmy in a 209 hitter
2-1 and that's it high in the air third
base side foul ground bregman has a play
moving toward the age dugout and he
makes the one-handed grab
julie hitting 250. 338 on base
percentage
euler with a line drive into right
center field yuli continues to be the
astro hitting the ball well along with
correa as he doubles to right center
field yuli had
two hits last night and starts off today
with a double great job on a fastball
middle up out over the plate he just
does a good job of lacing that into the
right center field gap
and guriel advances on the deep fly out
by correa but now two outs in the inning
now kyle tucker
left on left matchup here tucker hits a
high pop-up
lots of sunshine chapman
got it and we go to the bottom of the
second nothing nothing chris grossman is
batting 242
home run five rbis grossman
right field down the line and that
baby's gone
so robbie grossman's second home run of
the year both in this series and the a's
have an early one-nothing lead
unbelievable all the stuff that he can
throw when he gives him a
fastball 92 inner third of the plate
and robbie grossman gets the a's on the
board in this game
now matt olson will bat simeon and kemp
on the move on a 3-2 pitch
and here it is and it's hit to right
center and it's in well straws back
and that baby's gone
three versus one we'll take it so matt
olsen his fifth home run of the year and
fastball again down low that one does
some damage
now chapman bats he swings and he blasts
one left center field that's on his way
and the a's
have gone back to back a rocket from
matt chapman his fourth of the year and
it's five nothing oakland
blood in the water the a's offense
coming alive against the rookie
right-hander
so reddick aboard to lead off the fourth
inning here's bregman he bounced to
third his first time
it hard to chapman nice play at first
second on the first double play
wow not an easy play for matt chapman
was hit hard a little bit of an
in-between hop so now here's michael
brantley
last night they scored a run in the
ninth as brantley serves one into left
center field michael brantley goes the
other way for an extra base hit
that snaps an 0 for 14 for michael and
he's
a runner on second with two away and
here comes guerrielle
that ball is drilled to left field
pretty well hit all the way back and
that ball
is gone yuli guriel hits his third home
run of the year
and the astros get two runs back it's
now a five to two game
great swing by yulian a little bit of an
answer is the astros trying to fight
back in this game
lariano has flied out and struck out
oh that hits laureato looks like this
fastball just
gets away kind of spits out the side of
the hand here
either way ramon loriana does not want
to sew that one on
it but now twomin on for oakland with
nobody out
olson the difference in this game with a
three-run home run his last time up this
one he skies one way up in the air
yuli and val territory and the mask on
stumbling and bumbling and he falls over
the mound
flips it to redick as the runners
advance yuli hung in there for the out
but both runners advance
90 feet so it's 0-2 now to chapman
i'd leave that one out on the plate and
this is a long run again for yuli
circling and foul territory makes the
catch of simeon going to try and score
no how about julian fouled territory on
back-to-back plays
andre scrub is the new pitcher brandon
bailey leaves the game it's still
five two eight second and third canada
deep in the box he's ready scrub is
ready
kenneth hits it hard off scrub scrub
scrambles after it he's not gonna be
able to get to it in time it's gonna be
an infield hit
simeon comes in to score it at six to
two the a's lead
sverro batean comes out of the aspen to
work here in the sixth inning what's up
base is loaded
and korea's gonna hit and he got him
swinging he's kept it away from korea
and once again fatigue gets the is out
of a jam i think they turn it over to
birch smith
smith coming off an outing where he went
three in the third innings on wednesday
against the texas rangers as the astros
dug out getting on nick marley and
somebody's been tossed
nick marley has tossed somebody from the
astros dugout
it's been a tough stretch here with a
four-game losing streak and dusty baker
may have just been ejected from his
first
game as an astro manager and he'll take
the slow
stroll up the ramp and up to the
clubhouse
umberto castellanos coming in for the
third time now on this road trip
loriano bats
gets hit again that's the second time
now he's pointing at cassiano's it
looked like a breaking ball yeah
so everybody kind of standing around and
you can see lorianno just
kind of talking about you know it looks
like i can looks like i can feel him
releasing the ball in a fashion now
we've look out folks this is not a good
idea
this is not a good idea
sprinted toward the dugout and this is
not good folks
going back to the dugout so see if the
a's can pick up a two-out run as
matt chapman will hit although we did
see austin allen
that's a fair ball down the third base
line into the corner
and the a's will pick up an extra run as
pinder trots in to score
chapman with an rbi double and it's 7-2
kyle tucker the final hope for the
houston astros
and that's a swing and a miss and that's
the ball game oakland a's are the
hottest team in baseball folks